our heroes award deserve to be
remembered by more than just a faded
black-and-white photo and they deserve
to be remembered in full color I'm Nick
Harris and I restore and colorize it's
about ten years ago and my dad got hold
of a load of old photos of his dad and
and he was researching his family tree
at the time so when I saw those photos
in a kind of faded damaged State so I
wanted to take the photos enhance them
they'd have felt what they needed to
kind of enhance to be you know looked
after and preserved
[Music]
besides our topic leaving our gladden he
was dreaming his corpse went back again
so colorfully clearly has more impact
than a black-and-white photo and they
say that a picture paints his pals and
worked but that's certainly true when
it's in color but when it's in black and
white there's so many fine details that
are missed and when they're actually
colorized it completely brings it to
life and those fine details of their
uniforms their outfits their the
locations are needing our emotions
really come to life
it shows moments in history a rarely
seen in color except by the people that
were actually there when it comes to
research for the colors and I usually do
an internet search and hope to find this
and collectors aren't there that have
bought the uniforms and that really
helps weave getting all the fine details
of the colors and when it comes to skin
tones and hair times if it's not
something that's documented anywhere and
you can sometimes tell by the lights and
the darks or the tones of the gray there
hair if it's kind of an immediate gray
then it's possibly a light brown or
blonde and then if it's obviously more
darker than dark brown black so it's
kind of a bit of artistic license there
Cullen won't be so ago and for their re
f100 and re F Maurin got in touch and so
I colored and selection of photos for
then a mixture of World War one and
World War two photos so it's taking
those moments and bringing them to life
into Paulo
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
you
[Music]